[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
welcome to black man beyond my name is
martin arden my name is ming chen what
[Music]
uh
hey man hey how you doing good
excellent choice with the rush yyz oh
well you know it felt on brand
it didn't it felt like we're in the
right place for that
are you a rush fan because i don't i
when i was in college i was i was
obsessed with them
and then what i you know i was like this
is thinking man's nerd music all my
friends were in there like depeche mode
and all these bands didn't play their
own instruments i'm like no man
my life is getty lee alex lyson and new
parrot and that's all that is right
that's all that is r.i.p to neil like i
mean one of the greatest drummers ever
but my friends always made fun of me i
would not have made fun of you but uh i
i was i was not a fan
i appreciate but it's not the music of
my soul the way like run dmc is the
music of myself sure okay
peter popper picked peppers but one rock
rhymes something dumb you fell down on
yourself tom jack remember what nimble
but he was quick
yeah hey man
uh oh what what kind of nudity are we
getting involved in tonight uh i have
raspberry lemon from was uh acitron oh
crayon raspberry these are all open by
the way which means we can't put them to
waste no apparently but we were joking
if we ate if we drank all of these by
the end of the podcast so you'd be like
kevin smith you want to hear what kevin
smith i'll tell you what country let me
tell you a story yeah one time we killed
a hobo and i watched him do it and he
buried a body in the raritan bay silent
bobby ain't so silent he ain't so
excited he's not so funny
um
this this is the first time that ming
and i have actually podcasted together
yeah
which i think we've known each other
well oh 15 years maybe more than that
yeah i i first met ming when um
i think it was kevin was back in in
jersey doing poker games
and uh and he's like hey man do you want
to play poker and i said sure like a
sucker
and uh and says well uh ming will give
you give you all the information i was
like ming who
says don't worry about it and then i
didn't because then i would get an email
from me and you're like hey so here's
the date here's you know who's playing
here's where you go so go cool
and then we just would kind of [ __ ]
chat via email um because we are as very
many people in kevin's orbit are nerds
um but i never knew your beginning story
with kevin i don't know your origin
what's your secret origin yeah i don't
know yours either so we're getting both
our original story excellent um you go
first so we're gonna draw i i i i guess
this is a weird story as you know most
people like the journey is
you know go to school
you know get good grades go get a good
job go get married have family and all
that i was like no like i don't do
things i never do things normal so i met
kevin uh because i was a huge fan of
clerks so
uh
yeah wow okay we got a clerk's fan over
here all right
um when i was in college um where'd you
go to school university of michigan
uh good man go bloom and uh i my first
job there was at this really dumpy it
was a video game video store at the
student union
and it was so dumpy that uh we only got
one copy of each new movie that came
that would be released each week so
um
and uh one one week
this dirty little black and white movie
came in shot in new jersey called clerks
came in
and i i had heard it was funny um it
actually did play at our local indie
theater but like i wasn't an art house
kid like i didn't go see you know like
jim jarmisch movies or hal hartley
yeah so i thought it was black man i was
like this clerk's movie is this that's
you know nothing i'd be interested in
um but the vhs came in and instead of
checking it into the system so i could
rent it out to other people so the store
could make money and i could keep my job
i was like i'm going to take this home
and watch it
and i was also compounded with the girl
i was dating was from new jersey i was
like oh i'll watch this movie to get a
taste of where she's from
that's not the only taste you were
hoping for yeah no yeah i i needed yeah
so i went home my brother watched it and
i was i was completely blown away by
this movie i was like holy crap these
these guys talk like me and my friends
talk um
this guy put in a 10-minute conversation
about stormtroopers changing toilets on
the death star for god's stakes
i love this guy
and
um you know and a lot of people don't
remember in 94 no one was really talking
about star wars you know return the jedi
had come out 11 years before and george
was kind of like nope that's it i'm done
with the whole franchise except for me
and my friends every year we would watch
the movie multiple times we would quote
it and we didn't think anybody else did
this until i saw this movie so i i mean
i became obsessed with this movie it
would i
it awoke something inside me i don't i
can't describe it i'm sure some of you
guys might you know remember the first
time you saw clerks it was just so so
weird and different and
everything about the grainy black and
white uh you know the raunchy talk and
all that so
uh i think guys like me and you and us
nerds when we find something we love we
want to share with other people too
so
try to get all my friends to watch it
i'm like dude i just saw this awesome
movie you know there's a guy's changing
toys on the death star you know like
don't suck any deck out on the way to
the parking lot like you guys got to see
this
and they they're like well what
what's it about i'm like it's about two
guys in a convenience store
and
like well there are two guys outside the
convenience store too
and they're like
and and they're like wait is this this
isn't black and white like was it some
kind of art movie i'm like sort of
it's a art movie but
in and they refused to watch it and in a
world where you know it's like 94 right
you got clerks they got pulp fiction
stargate forest gump uh 94 is a very
good year for blockbuster movies they
chose to watch the other ones instead
[ __ ] so yeah exactly
so i could not get any of my friends to
watch it i really i did all this stuff i
wanted to get it like just talk to
people you know i was like oh remember
remember when randall gets hit in the
head with a loaf of bread like that was
awesome stuff like that so i
coincidentally at that time i was
learning how to build websites
i met this weird dude in the engineering
school taught me how to code and stuff
and i was like i'm gonna build a fan
clerk's website and that way i could
find people from around the world to
who maybe have seen the movie
and will talk to me about it and like i
was just a lonely nerd i mean i know we
have bringing people together [ __ ]
noble cause yeah so i did i put up a
really what i thought was a really cool
clerk's fan website um
and there were a couple out there
already but i wanted mine to be the
ultimate so what i did is i went to
tower records when when that was when
those were still around i bought the
laserdisc because i had all this bonus
uh cut scenes it had the lost ending
like some of you may or may not dante
get shot at the end but they cut out
that ending
yeah
yeah there's a lost ending where dante
gets shot at the end and he's left for
dead and that and then the movie ends
right there
that's [ __ ] dark it is yeah
like good cut kev yes
i don't think anybody really wants that
i remember i think someone had sundance
was like why did you end it like that
he's like what don't all indie movies
end like that
and like they don't have to like you
yeah the guy was like you built this guy
all up the whole movie and you shoot him
at the end and they're like you got to
cut that so that guy may have been with
harvey weinstein like you know
the devil we will not name yeah so i may
i made this fan website and lo and
behold people were on the world i had my
email address on the bottom was like hey
if you like clerks too
send me an email and lo meow people
around the world started contacting me i
was like hey man yeah
jin sam bob huh i'm like yeah man
they're awesome
um and then lo and behold one day the
biggest clerks fan in the world
contacted me kevin
had
seen the he pulled up the website at an
internet cafe in red bank and he i guess
he was impressed by it i wasn't sure but
he tracked down my number
and he gave me a call one day
and i didn't know why he was calling
um did you believe it was him
uh
um i mean once i heard the voice well so
actually hey man actually i got an email
with the number and it was from him i
was like hey give me a call tomorrow and
i thought
i thought okay either he can he really
liked it
or uh you know you know i told you i
ripped off the laserdisc and put it on a
website
um i forgot conveniently there's a thing
called copyright law in this country
and you know i i feel i'm exempt from
that because my people don't adhere to
this law we feel like stuff all the time
no i mean you you clearly have a genetic
disposition to not have to follow that
law right right i was like hey man like
you know i know you know
you already put it out already i'm just
helping other people see it right it's
i'm i'm i'm assisting people you're an
evangelist i am yeah uh he sent me you
know he's like give me a call this
number i was like holy crap either this
go really good or really bad i'm like
what the hell i'll call the number
and so i ring the number it's a 908 area
code so which is new jersey i'm like
okay this looks legit so i call the
number at the appointed time
and the phone picks up and i'm like hey
i hear the other end oh
i'm like
all right this is weird i'm like hi my
name is ming uh kevin smith
told me to call him at this time is he
there and you're like he's not here
right now
i'm like oh
okay well here's my number can you have
him call me back
okay
phone hangs up
and i was like wow that really that
sounded like that jay guy from that
clerk's movie
and it was it was that jay guy from that
movie i don't know why he was answering
phones that day like why he was a
receptionist but i guess they they some
they were short-handed he lost a bet he
may have lost a bed put his dick on
something he should have buzzed probably
like you got to answer phones now yeah
so like 20 minutes later i get a call
back from that number and it's it's a
voice that they're like hey man how you
doing i was like holy sh holy [ __ ] i
think that sounds like the silent pop
guy
i'm like hey what's going on and he was
like hey i saw your website and i
hesitate so i don't know how it's to go
like i'm about to press the button that
that destroys all my computer equipment
burns all the hard drives like gene
hackman and um that enemy of the state
but he's like hey man
i like i just saw your website i like
what you did i was like woof okay we're
good on that i'm not going no fbi is
going to come crashing through the door
and uh he was like hey i i saw you did
it looks really good i think this
internet thing is going to take off
can you build me more of these websites
so keep in mind this is 90 1995. so
there's no google no twitter no
instagram no amazon no no facebook none
of this stuff
um but i think what he's he liked what i
built he wanted more because he was he
had just finished mall rats
he was kind of depressed that it didn't
do so well yeah man
he was about to go into production and
chasing amy and um he was like hey do
you think we could use this website
stuff to reach more of my fans
is there any way maybe i can interact
with the people who do like my movies
and uh maybe you know maybe that'll help
me
promote all the stuff i i'm gonna do
can you build me more websites for the
movies i'm you know i have in this on
the slay i'm doing chasing gaming
there's this weird movie called dogma
with angels and poop monsters and i got
all this stuff and now i was like i was
like absolutely i can help you out um
just let me know what you need so yeah
he sent me his whole list he was like
hey what's your address and i gave it to
him
and uh the next day a fedex box shows up
and you know that line in um was it uh
what's that what's the uh the steve
martin eddie murphy movie
finger ball finger you know at the end
of both fingers like you're not anyone
you know you're somebody when you
finally get a fedex like that's how you
know you've made it and i got a fedex
box i'm a college kid
so you know i have no business getting a
fedex but i had a fedex and what he sent
me was eight by ten hard copy stills
from mall rats
um three by five black and white stills
from clerks um some some programs from
like the ken's film festival
like i opened this up to me as a as a
kevin smith fan like it
it might as well been george lucas
sending me a lightsaber because that's
how cool it was i was like holy crap he
sent me
like
you know real you know possibly
irreplaceable rare things that he wanted
me to put on the website so
um so you send me a list of stuff like
hey can we do a section about my movies
uh you know a news uh a gallery i've
never seen four photos um stuff like
that but he's like you know what i
really want is some can you build me
like a chat room
um and kevin to this day still has an
aol address so he was an aol kid even
way back in 95 that was his first taste
of the internet
and i'm like wait you want to like an
aol chat room like you want to pick up
chicks on your website
because that's what people did right
there people were they were like cyber
sexting or whatever
dude it was just people making
connections sure why you gotta like
[ __ ] slam on that [ __ ] no
the dialing up trying to get some
downloading katherine janeway porn very
slowly
it's like you were in my bedroom
i was
[Laughter]
oh i was like it was like no no idiot i
want to talk to my fans on this chat
room i'm like
naked yeah i was like well let me see
i'm sure i could arrange that and i
started doing research and i went back
to him i was like hey chat room would be
cool but you'd probably have to schedule
time to you know interact with people i
know you're a very busy man
um
i but i found this other thing it's a
it's a message board software where
people can post questions and then you
can go down and answer them whenever you
have time so you can either answer one
question you could sit there for two
hours and answer 100 of them
i just think it'd be way more you know
conducive to your schedule and efficient
um so that's what so that's what i built
and um
it was cool we built this whole kind of
community it was we did so it was social
media before there was any social media
and we ended up gathering those people
for like all day film festivals in red
bank new jersey
and uh it was cool like we'd do a marat
screening we had he'd fly out like jason
lee and ethan sue plea to do q a at the
end like we really kind of built this
whole thing before uh you know there was
any twitter or or anything it was really
yeah it was really cool and oddly not
that message board we built it looks
exactly like reddit does know so like
we're waiting for our checks man we're
way i think because i'm pretty sure we
invented reddit so i think you did i
think
uh um just like you know you were the
guy who invented [ __ ] napster and
yeah seth green yeah so
it was cool so yeah i was in college i
ended up graduating
and um i ended up getting a real job
and uh you know doing website stuff um i
you know um putting kevin on my resume
probably didn't hurt getting hired
because i got hired right away there's a
big demand for this stuff back in the
late 90s
um
but i i
think the thing i like telling kids is
that you know the job i had like i
didn't really love it i was working for
a tech non-profit building websites
wasn't really that great but i was but
by night though when i went home at
night i would work on viewer skew kevin
smith stuff
and it was it was cool because it was
kind of cool having that just positions
like i worked on something i didn't
really care about by day but by night i
would like i put all my heart and soul
into it knowing that i had something to
compare it to you were batman i was
batman exactly [ __ ] batman i was like
by day i gotta pretend to give a [ __ ]
about this corporate world but by night
yes i'm gonna get down i'm gonna get
down with kevin smith
wait a minute hold on
yeah it was yeah it was pretty cool
those are like really fun times like uh
yeah because kevin's always been a very
progressive guy he's always one step
ahead
of everybody else with like technology
or just where things are going and this
was one of them so it's really cool to
be at the forefront of that
and um i think one of the greatest days
of my life was that kevin was like hey
did you get entertainment weekly this
week i'm like
no why he's like check it out flip to
page 54 i'm like okay so i went and
bought it and
you know how they used to review movies
and give them letter grades they started
reviewing websites on this issue
and i flipped to that and there was a
review for the viewer sku kevin smith
website and they gave me an a
they gave me an a for the website
they're like this is the mecca for
kevin smith fans everywhere there's a
whole thing and you know you work for
entertainment you wrote reviews you know
how hard it is to get an a grade for
anything it ain't easy i think they gave
pulp fiction like a c minus or something
right
yeah they were harsh man they they they
gave pulp fiction an a i remember that
oh did they okay or they did give an a
okay yeah um but they they could be they
could be harsh mistresses the the the
critics at ew but yeah i mean it was a
good [ __ ] website dude it was one of
the first at the door to do that thing
and connect people with what they wanted
yeah yeah it was it was really fun and
uh yeah eventually yeah i worked at
corporate job for a while
um
there there was a period i think right
around goodwill hunting where uh we
would have special guests hop on the the
message board
so i i remember one day for whatever
reason cameron crowe started posting and
we we talked we could tell with him
because video is very specific in his
posts i am cameron crowe yeah i was like
okay i believe he was very specific on
the details it was it was really him and
uh yeah i remember he went after one
poster
who called uh jerry maguire jerry mcshit
and he went after him he's like well as
the writer and director of jerry mcshit
i i would like to rebut this argument
and he did in detail
it was cool and then affleck started
posting
a lot
to the point where kevin was like dude
can you just go get your own [ __ ]
website like stop posting on mine
so affleck contacted me it was like hey
kevin says i had to get my own website
can you build one for me same thing
message board and all that
and um yeah so i did
and um
yeah bill i i don't know how this
happened you know kevin kevin makes
weird things happen cost you one million
dollars affleck in charge of a million i
judge him far less than a million you
coulda though yeah um and uh so i bought
this website he was pretty impressed by
coincidentally at the same time him and
matt damon had started an internet
startup company in the 2000s called live
planet
and they had a property they they had
released called project greenlight on
hbo which some of you may have
remembered which was a script writing
competition
and uh so they like hey we got this
company uh you seem to know what you're
doing like do you do
we want to hire you
i'm like oh okay yeah i'll come work for
you guys uh they're like what's your
number
and uh you know your phone number yeah i
i threw it a fairly crazy salary number
that i go alright done i was like whoa
really
i could ask for that yeah yeah yeah i
should i probably should have so uh i
actually end up working for uh ben and
matt for a year i moved out to la for a
year your time in the sun hollywood ming
yeah it was cool it was cool although
it's a startup so you know like you do a
serious work like it wasn't fly by night
so we had way to work startup hours
which was nine to seven which in l.a
like a ten hour day is pretty long even
even in a startup world and it was all
going great until 9 11 and that kind of
crushed everything so
um
uh yeah one day they called us all in
there i listened um you know 911 kind of
screwed up a lot of things we had
planned and you're all being laid off
and i yeah and i was like crap man and i
remember i emailed kevin i was like hey
man i don't know if you heard we all got
laid off uh you know um i gotta go look
for another job
i'm gonna put your name your name on my
resume if anybody calls could you you
know put in some good words for me
and he was like hey man you wanna come
work for me full time i think this is
what this is how it was meant to be
always um
you know do you wanna come work for me i
was like holy crap that was a quick
turnaround like yes i do yeah so i i was
like dude i would love to come work for
you full-time and uh you know i was just
kind of doing it on the side up until
this point
and he's like okay but one caveat
you gotta move to new jersey
and i was like all right i saw that
clerk's movie it's so you guys ain't so
tough out there
um
and i was like well you know i i would
have loved to stay in la i guess but uh
i'll move to new jersey to work
full-time for for kevin and be part of
the gang out there
and uh
and and i did so i've been there ever
since i moved out there in 2002 so i've
been there almost 20 years
um the
yeah the
the monkey wrench and all that i got out
there and you know there was an office
and kevin had his big office and they
gave me an office and uh
i was working out there two months later
i remember he comes into my office he's
like hey man you'll never guess what's
what happened i'm like what's going on
it's like i'm moving to l.a
i'm like what he's like yeah yeah i
bought ben affleck's old house i'm
moving to l.a i'm like so i could have
stayed out there you mean he's like no
no just come follow me in five years
like you know move out and you know set
up an office out there and it never
happened i couldn't i could not leave
the east coast
after getting a taste of it the pizza
and the bagels are too good you know
this i know this it's so [ __ ] hard in
l.a to get decent pizza bagels or
chinese food yeah um so no that's that
was a good choice i feel like you made a
sound decision yeah and it worked out
there's still there's still an office
out there the store he couldn't move the
store out there um he did give a la
there was a la secret stash for a year
or two that didn't really work out
um but yeah thank god i stayed out there
i mean
uh you know long story short we ended up
uh
podcasting he introduced me to
podcasting that led to comic book men
and uh yeah that leads me to where i am
now in the beautiful city of prince
george british columbia sitting next to
the amazing mark bernard and all you
guys so wow yeah i mean but the moral of
the story is uh you know i i this all
happened because i really loved
something and uh i channeled my fandom
into
something else that i love which was you
know build being a geek building
websites
and uh and just kind of helping out
somebody that i really admired and um
it back then it was kind of a long shot
there was no way to contact anybody you
admired um on the like anyone like
anybody's really accessible yeah
yeah now like you know the the former
president of the united states can block
you on twitter you know
yeah but back then yeah you couldn't you
couldn't really do that so i think i
don't know i don't mess with like fate
and destiny and i think that kind of
that kind of worked out but i always
tell kids or anybody needs advice like
just do what you love eventually
it probably will probably work out in
one way or the
this is other sponsoring
uh this week's episode of fat man beyond
we have two sponsors and the first
uh is one that i can speak to
uh very
knowledgeably
uh
it's a good folks ladies and gentlemen
that's sheath
that's right if you want to follow along
go to uh sheath dot com sheath underwear
all one word
dot com and sheath is s-h-e-a-t-h
underwear.com fat man
as i give you the lowdown on sheath this
is brilliant
brilliant underwear not in our lifetime
we have seen the advent of many a
product ladies and gentlemen a lot of us
have seen the advent of the internet if
you've been around since the [ __ ] 90s
but this is the advent of [ __ ] dick
and ball comfort in underwears
uh sheath
created a pouch
to stick your junk into and when i say
junk kids i'm talking about your dick
and balls if you got one of those you
know that it sticks on your leg from
time to time if you're a heavyset
gentleman like myself and you got your
mom's childbearing thighs you're
sticking all over the place and you're
readjusting you're always moving your
gate wide when you're walking down a
hill and [ __ ] because they're just
peeling away like you're picking a
[ __ ] color for him off the mat and
[ __ ]
well some genius who was in the military
figured out like you know what what if
there was underwear that just had a
[ __ ] pouch in it like a reverse
kangaroo pouch man and your dick and
balls were the joey and you just stuffed
them in there so that they were all
compartmentalized separate from the rest
yeah why did it take so long it gets a
patch and your balls get a pouch there
are so many there's there's so much
architecture and engineering going on in
your crotch if you're wearing sheath
it's like it's like a deluxe apartment
between your thighs yes between your
thighs you're moving on up with sheath
i um was sent a bunch of sheath
underwear
unfortunately the good folks at sheath
think i'm a slighter man than i am mark
but i gave those sheath underwear uh to
my brother don
my beloved brother donald
um
who uh has been married to my
brother-in-law jerry for uh
almost 30 years old as long as old as
clerks is clerks
was released
27 years ago today
so i think don and jerry been married
for at least 27 years um in any event i
gave my brother the sheath underwear
this is what we talk about all the time
oh my god those underwear man i'm like
seriously he's like changed my life he's
like i had no idea that i wanted two
separate compartments for my dick and
balls
um
that's a [ __ ] vote of confidence
from a guy who knows how to wear
underwear
my brother don't doubt that
man knows how to wear underwear it's
huge praise he's older than me i'm 51
he's you know of course they're like
that's what we want [ __ ] the vote of
the elderly i'm 51 he's four years older
than me to the day we share the same
birthday
it says a 55 year old man extolling the
virtues of a pair of [ __ ] underwear
that's how brilliant they are when
you're 55 kids you've seen it at all
nothing impresses you anymore
um
but what my brother was truly impressed
and still continues to be impressed
by sheath man
you will be too
all you have to do
sheath underwear dot com slash fat man
and order up some underwear what are
they going to give them a discount of
some sort correct
20
off my friend
20 off
the only deal better than that you're
ever gonna get is if you're my brother
and i just give you some free sheath
underwear
so what are you waiting for man make us
look good to the good folks at [ __ ]
sheath it was invented by a goddamn
[ __ ] soldier man like how brilliant
is that man he figured out when he was
in iraq he was like my [ __ ] is sticky
and he inverted his underwear and
created a [ __ ] piece of his own
company came home created a goddamn
company
so
show him that uh you know you like
underwear that you agree with this idea
i'm telling you
it's time has come
your balls treat them well
sheath underwear dot com slash fat man
20 off what are you waiting for
hug them
hug your balls
hey
you put your gun in a holster if you're
that kind of person
uh why not put your [ __ ]
fleshy gun at that in the holster it all
fell apart but you know
there's a thought that counts yes put
your you know protect your
put your
bag and board your dick and balls with
sheath there you go it's kind of on
brand for our audience ooh nice
uh we thank the good folks at sheath not
just for making a brilliant piece of uh
[ __ ] garmin why'd it take this
[ __ ] long who knew like this think
about how medieval underwear is
i mean
boxers even more than briefs for
heaven's sakes and finally somebody's
like i got a way forward i'm gonna
introduce you to a [ __ ] underwear you
had never seen before and you can't
believe it's never been done before so
we thank them for their brilliance but
we also thank them for sponsoring
our incompetence here at fat man bm
indeed
a sock for your [ __ ] sheath underwear
com slash fat man there's a [ __ ]
writer right down there there's a writer
ladies and gentlemen like
look at that little writer just writing
copy yeah
that was good say it again
suck for your [ __ ] sheath underwear
i'd like to direct that commercial
to be a total super bowl ad tell me they
wouldn't talk about that if that was a
super health a sock for your [ __ ] sheath
i could do a 15 second read it'll be the
most talked about [ __ ] ad we wouldn't
even have to show the [ __ ] or the sock
just saying it you picked the right
person to say that
[ __ ] morgan freeman
sucks
and it's and it's just it's like a snake
trying on a sweater that's just the
whole [ __ ] hat
sheath give us a call we got ideas
[Music]
yeah
kev also always sort of he says
find what you love and then find a way
to get paid for it now
yeah which you know sometimes easier
than done but
usually far harder than than it might
seem but yeah it's it's a decent path to
try and walk down yeah
and i remember i just this memory came
up the uh i remember i'd
i had to go pick up kevin at the airport
in philadelphia for some reason and i
can't remember where i took him but i
i remember that day after i picked up he
copped in the car i think that was the
day you had been let go from
entertainment weekly was that kind of uh
like a dark day oh it was like it was it
was the the
the juncture of the timelines it was
okay the that's the nexus yeah that's
where that's where when you're at the
the [ __ ] point at the end of the
universe and loki
that's where i ended up in like the
wrong room where the timeline got all
[ __ ] up and i'm like yeah i was
supposed to be doing this forever and
you laid me off you [ __ ] yeah
you were there for 20 years i was there
for no 13 years 13 okay 13 years yeah i
remember he got in the car and and i
don't know why i was making small talk i
was like hey man you hear about mark and
he's like what's going on and i keep
entertaining weekly man
they let him go and he was like oh man
that sucks but i remember our
conversation he's like man we don't
really have to worry about him like
he'll be fine that was our conversation
i remember that i remember very vividly
like that's the conversation plan was
i did this yeah we knew you were fine we
knew you were you know we knew i mean we
just knew everything would be all right
but it just it was kind of a bombshell
in the inner the entertainment world
there was a whole article about it yeah
it was it was uh it was a weird day like
i had never been i had never been fired
before
um
and uh
and it sucks there's kind of like no
candy coating it but it
and i couldn't have known at the time
because when you're in the middle of
that it's all just like raw nerves and
and exposed flesh and your tender
underbellies being prodded and poked
yeah um but it was the best thing that
could have happened to me career-wise
yeah because i never would have left um
because it was a good job like i was
cushy like they paid me well and i got
to do fun [ __ ] but i couldn't do the
thing that i needed to do which was
eventually start to write tv yeah until
i left there and i never would have left
so if they hadn't fired me i'd still be
working there right um so i'm glad they
did thanks gang
now
yeah how did you be kevin i have no idea
all i remember is he's like hey this guy
is aw cool like
make sure he makes it to the poker game
[Music]
that way and that was it just slid a
name under the door this guy's gonna
play pokemon yeah um no i met kev
um a couple different times before
we got to be friendly because i
interviewed him a couple times for
entertainment weekly said magazine
talking about it a bit um
first time i interviewed him was i was
doing this dumb [ __ ] um
sort of listing of the best superhero
costumes oh
and uh and my editor at the time was
like we need a quote from somebody who
knows something about something in in
this in this world um so you even get to
kevin smith and i was like all right
[ __ ] i'll see you i called kevin's
publicist and he's like yeah sure this
easy so i got kevin on the phone and
we're talking about like all right
superman versus batman versus too much
coffee man versus
and he just [ __ ] he gave me what i
needed yeah i was like yeah he's a bit
more lagerfeld he's a little bit more
like ooh you were like deep into fashion
dude he's like well i got a girlfriend
who like likes to wear clothes yeah and
uh and so then that was it like had him
on the phone for 10 minutes and it was
it was a fun enough ten minutes and it
went away i mean like a year after that
i think it was jersey girl was coming
out
and i wanted to do a filmography i
wanted to like just [ __ ] talk to kev
about each one of his movies and i'll
get quotes and anecdotes and whatever
and uh so reach back out to his
publicist and like kevin emails me back
directly he's like hey man this sounds
like fun happy to do it but could we do
it over instant message
because i'm a writer and i don't want to
talk so much
he had he hadn't yet turned the corner
to be the dude who just wanted to talk
all the time i was like i'm right i just
don't want to talk so much i'm like
great i'm lazy and i don't want to
transcribe a whole [ __ ] interview
yeah so copy and paste right be paced
i'm like dude this is a dream
and so we spent like two hours [ __ ]
justing back and forth and going down
his movies and telling me stories and i
just cut and pasted and put in the
article
but he then still had my i am address
right so like every couple weeks i get
some items like hey man
uh should i use a colon or a semicolon
in this sentence like you're an editor
for grammar advice
at first it was like you're a [ __ ]
editor man you know what i should use
and i was like i was like well what's
the context of the sense it's like i'll
tell you and it was the letter he was
writing um
to get harley into private school
so she must have been like four or five
years old whatever it was and so he's
like you know
i'm just trying to prepare my daughter
for success
semicolon or colon
i was like you do [ __ ] dash man
nobody knows what the difference is
between two cultures all right cool and
then after that he would just start i
aiming me about like hey man did you see
the hulk and i'd say yeah saw the hulk
it was weird it's like i know right and
it would just be these instant message
versions of the conversations you'd have
with your friends in a movie at like two
o'clock in the morning outside the
multiplex like sitting on the hood of
somebody's car
but i guess he just wanted to [ __ ] do
that so like yeah man whatever and then
he was like oh do you play poker
uh and then that's when ming enters a
story and ming connected me to this
poker game and i'd go into the back of
the secret stash in red bank which the
stash up front is a comic book story
right we've all seen it yeah but by
night by night it's like a [ __ ]
speakeasy for illicit gamble
and all kinds of weird ass [ __ ] so like
you go back there and there's like nine
tables like [ __ ] casino style tables
set up in the back here and
you know you're just [ __ ] rolling up
it looked like the chesterfield club
from rounders yeah very much so yeah
except we didn't have funka jensen which
there was no funkas there's no [ __ ]
chance there's lots of ed norton's with
us
a lot of worms for sure a lot of worms
you know so you roll up and like and the
thing that amazed me was that he would
hold these games like once a month now
once every two months he'd fly in from
la and people would drive
from like i drove for 24 hours to get
him yeah like i just came in from
calgary or i just drove in from maine
right just drove up from miami to come
and play poker with kevin
maybe not actually get to sit at a table
with him right
it was a 30-person tournament 30-person
journey and you know we sat everywhere
randomly totally and you know so to just
kind of get to go there and then be in
the room and then every hour you take a
smoke break and to like kind of go
behind the stash and hang out and talk
to kev and
clearly everybody there was more
invested in talking to kev than i was
because again i drove 10 minutes because
i lived in [ __ ] jersey yeah um
but you know just kind of getting to
know him and whatever and i'd go out to
la because i would go from jersey to l.a
a couple times a year
and like the first time i went he's like
hey do you want to come see the movie
i was like uh
what movie it was oh zach and miri like
it's finished i got to cut in the house
you want to come over and watch it i
said yeah okay sure that sounds like fun
and i called my wife like apparently i'm
going to kevin smith's house to watch a
movie she's like what movie his new
movie really yeah that that was brutal
movie the porno movie movie it's like
what's going on with you and kevin smith
it's like nothing we're just gonna watch
a porno together it's totally cool
straight things do this all the time
and uh and so i go to his house and i
expect to be watching the movie with him
and instead he's like i'm gonna put it
on i'll see you in about two hours and
then he leaves and i'm sitting in his
house so you're like there by yourself
and then
that big-ass roommate at the top
i'm like okay this is what's happening
and so i watched the movie and i chuckle
and because it's a funny movie and it's
a sweet movie and it's a dirty movie um
all of which i like and uh and it goes
back there is a car so what'd you think
and i was like well dude it's sweeter
than it is funny and it's very funny
it's like excellent that's exactly what
i was hoping you would say
and i would just [ __ ] talk for like
three hours yeah you know like he had
just started smoking weed because zach
zach and zack and miri is the the
dividing line between cigarettes and
marijuana right that's his nexus point
yeah was the moment he met a gentleman
named seth rogen yeah who introduced him
to the marijuana he blazed a different
trail literally
literally
and so like he's smoking up and we order
pizza and we're just [ __ ] talking
about nerd [ __ ] until like two o'clock
in the morning i'm like i gotta go back
to my hotel because i think i gotta go
to work tomorrow
um sorry man cool this was fun
so i go about my life and then the next
time i'm in la is before uh i was i was
just on staff on alphas at the time yeah
and i'd moved to to la for the summer
and he's like oh you're here cool i do
this podcast with my wife um every
morning called plus one per diem um do
you want to be a guest on the show i was
like yeah [ __ ] up why the hell not drove
over this house like eight o'clock in
the morning and i think that was the
first time i met jen or maybe i met her
at zach and miriam but either way it was
you know she welcomes me to the house
and i go up and we talk for an hour and
we tell stories he was like oh cool man
that was fun thanks and then i go about
my life
and then
i
moved back to new jersey
uh still coming out to l.a every now and
again but next time i was in l.a i was
like hey so i do this podcast called fat
man on batman
think of some batman stories um come be
a guest just think like your 10 favorite
batman moments i'm like alright cool i
can do that i make this list um and it's
like no no no all right flack on the
play we're gonna do a commentary track
for the the dark knight returns animated
movie uh part one so watch the movie and
then come over we'll do a commentary
track i'm like all right cool so we do
that he's like that was fun let's do all
the batman movies
okay all right sure
and so we do all the batman movies um
you know i think like batman and robin
took something out of us yeah because
this isn't fun anymore like oh this is
it's torture
this hurts
um and so then we were like all right
well we don't have any more batman
movies this is a pretty dark night yeah
dark night coming out uh or pre-batman
begins and then um i was like all right
let's do gotham cool they got a batman
story every week let's [ __ ] do gotham
yeah and then we got like three episodes
into gotham
we're like well what if we don't do
gotham anymore um
but we had this segment of the podcast
we used to call the utility belt right
which was like all right we're gonna
start a little chit chat how are you
going what are you up to i'm doing this
uh and then cover like the nerd news yes
have the utility belt and we'd unpack
the utility belt and talk about whatever
was happening and then get into gotham
and eventually we're like what if we
don't do that but we just do the utility
belt yes
i said okay it was like hey do you want
to be the co-host of this podcast
i was like what does that mean he goes
just show up and be like i don't have to
book guests i don't have to like do
books or logistics or keep a schedule no
just whenever recordings show up like i
can do that
um so we do that for a little while and
it's like hey man
uh do you mind if we set up some cameras
in my in my office um we're going to try
like streaming this onto youtube or
something i'm like yeah sure it's your
house
um and it's like hey man um
do you want to
do do you want to do this in like a
studio get out of my house because this
is weird i'm like sure if you want to
figure that [ __ ] out and have you show
up it's like great hey man do you want
to go on the road i'm like
okay okay it's like yeah we can i feel
like we can book this yeah so you want
to go to like detroit in a month
okay
i was like hey man
um
we're gonna do it at comic-con it's like
oh that's awesome it feels like
homecoming she would be we should be
there all the time
he's like hey man so
jc uh the guy who's been producing the
show has bought a bar should we do like
a permanent residency at the bar
like absolutely we should because i'm a
degenerate and if i get to go to work at
a bar and not have to work at the bar
yeah free drinks
amazing yeah [ __ ] yeah i love the smell
of dried alcohol and a weird rubber mat
at the bottom but it wasn't any ordinary
bar it's the nerdiest bar you've ever
been to it's the scum and villainy
cantina that's in
hollywood boulevard
in hollywood california and it is a
wretched hive of scum and villainy
exactly as one would imagine by the name
and so and it looks so much like the
star wars cantina like i don't know how
he's not gotten sued yet it looks more
like the star wars cantina than the
actual cantina they built the galaxies
oh they are the ogres cantina yeah and
so people go to that one they come to
scrum and villain he's like yeah this is
better yeah i don't have to wait in line
for this yeah and also i get real booze
yeah tater tots this is [ __ ] rocks
um
and so basically i i have built an
entire side hustle out of saying yes to
kevin whenever he says hey man
wow what a coincidence because i get
that hey man all the time
that hey man is dangerous and it's
awesome you know it always promises
something there's always an adventure
the other side of hey man yeah um
and uh and yeah and then it every now
and again it's like hey man uh i i think
i want to try and do a a a question mini
series uh limited series for tv like dc
reached out asked me if i wanted to do
it that's what i want to do and so we
spent like two weeks breaking a 10
episode question series because that is
kevin's favorite dc character ever more
so than batman he wants to do the
question
and but it turns out that dc somehow did
not have the rights to their own
character
and they were like yeah so the chain of
title isn't clear and we can't make a tv
show we can make more comics do you want
to do comics it was like nah
um
and so that died and then i was like hey
man how do you feel about he-man
and i said
i'm a bit agnostic on him and if you
don't have fun to catch then i will go
with you hard on thundercats oh yeah
thunder thunder thundercats
like that was my [ __ ] move like
and it was a it was a generation it was
an age thing yeah like i kind of just
aged out i think of cartoons you know
when he-man sort of came in but
thundercats i was kind of all about yeah
but i was like no like [ __ ] he-man
all right i understand i know what it is
clearly i have some affinity for it but
i'm just not a die-hard fan he's like
that's perfect i'm the die hard fan i
have a couple of other die hard fans you
get to be the dude who says does that
make sense as a [ __ ] story right you
know are we doing enough character work
are we making people are we making
people cry with this because if we're
not then we're doing it wrong and so i
said yeah [ __ ] it i'll strap in for some
mass of the universe and
i i have yet to regret saying yes to a
hey man yeah
i
[Laughter]
not yeah neither have i i um
led to me to led me to some very weird
and awesome places for sure so what is
the weirdest awesomest place that a hay
man
has found you um i think there's
probably the uh
jeez i mean there there are there are a
couple of them um i think the one that
really comes to mind was like
uh there was one friday afternoon in
january in 2011.
the weekend's about to come up i'm about
to wrap things up and i get the the
instant message
for years
kevin only commuted it communicated
pretty much through aol instant
messenger
and i get i get the hey man through hey
man but through instant messenger he's
like hey man what are you doing this
weekend
i'm like what am i doing this weekend
he's like well all right i just you know
we just wrapped the movie red state
and
i have a secret mission for you
i'm like okay what does this entail so i
was like i'm going to send you the only
copy of the movie we have on dvd this is
a movie that we use self finance for
where four million dollars
this is the only copy of the dvd and it
cannot fall into the wrong hands because
if it does we can't distribute it you
know you know god forbid the chinese get
their hands on it and they and then they
bootleg it so i'm going to give it to
you right yeah
i was a trusted minion employee at that
point
so what he wanted me to yeah
what he wanted me to do was he wanted me
to drive it up to uh to maine an eight
hour drive to a place called brunswick
maine there is a i believe she was a new
york times
film critic uh by the name of mary f
poles
and she did not leave maine
the only way that they could get here to
review the movie is if i drove up a copy
up to her um but that wasn't the sole
purpose of my mission
my mission was to drive it up without he
he gave me specific instructions do not
let the dvd leave your site so if you go
to the bathroom take it with you if you
go to a restaurant take it with you if
you stop and get cast take it with you
like no matter where you go do not let
it leave your sight it's that important
it's you know it's the nuclear football
so like i didn't handcuff it to my my
wrist but i might as well have at that
point um if you go to the hotel lock it
in the safe you know like it gave me all
these instructions
uh but the real mission was to go to her
house in maine
watch it with her
make sure she didn't bootleg it
and um and which new york times film
critics did all the yes of course yeah
especially you know like you know little
middle-aged film critics in maine yeah
they were really really afraid it would
fall into the wrong hands so it did feel
like you know nuclear codes or something
and i was like oh okay i'll yeah i'm
sure i'm i'll you know so i was like all
right i'm going to send it fedex you to
you
you'll have it tomorrow morning and then
your mission your mission begins you
know this message will self-destruct in
five seconds
and i was okay i was like well what do
you know like what do i just sit there
and watch it with her he's like yeah
just make sure she doesn't sneak off and
boot like it
uh while you're there
and i'm like well do i should i talk to
her they're like no he's like don't even
talk to her yeah they were giving me
instructions like you know that that old
adage is like you know um you know just
don't open your mouth and sound like a
fool or whatever right um but i had
never seen the movie before so i drove
the eight hours up there i did not leave
it on my side i took i it was hanging
off my wrist when i was taking a whiz in
the at the urinal
um oh [ __ ] i splashed it yeah yeah all
that stuff and uh yeah and
and uh i got yeah
i got it up there very nice woman she
bought me tim horton's donuts while we
were watching the movie but you didn't
say anything because you can't talk to
her that's not true
miming thank you using like you guys
know me i can't not talk to people so
yeah we were making small talk she had a
ten-year-old son that she sent the
hockey so we would have a good two hours
to watch the movie nice and i i had not
seen it either so i remember being blown
away by redstone holy crap kevin smith
made this movie with john goodman and
all this violence and and like like cool
shots like i wouldn't i would have never
known it was him if if no one told me
and
yeah at the end she's like so wow i was
like what'd you think i was like what
what do i do now should i
if i say my opinion will i sway hers and
uh but i was like wow that was really it
was really intense we talked for a
little while and then uh she sent me on
my way and my instructions were to
immediately drive it back and destroy it
um but before i actually got into the
office i cut through the comic book shop
and walt flanagan was there from comic
book man he was like hey man what is
that i'm like oh it's a copy of red
state i gotta you know cam and sent me
on a mission he's like hey can i i want
to watch it can i borrow it i'm like
no
i'm like no and he got really mad at me
he's like wait you don't trust me i'm
like it's not a question i trust
i can't let it fall into the wrong hands
he was mad at me for like a year he was
really offended that i wouldn't let him
take it home without my supervision
and watch it he didn't understand how
important that this copy was i feel like
that red state dvd is like the watch in
pulp fiction
yes you don't know what my dad went
through to get me this squad you don't
know what i just did in maine just hung
out with this old lady and didn't say
anything when she watched the movie and
asked me questions and i had to refuse
her right and yeah just gonna [ __ ]
watch it yeah stuff my face with donuts
like i tried to show no emotion
yeah uh yeah he was mad at me for you
for a long time he was really offended
i'm like dude he's like when me and
kevin are friends it's cool i'm like no
it's not cool that's just that this
cannot fall into the wrong hands you do
not understand
so i remember yeah once i put it in that
shredder in the office like i had a like
a huge weight lifted off
you also could have destroyed it in
maine
i
i yeah i guess i could have but
probably could have my instructions were
to bring it back to jersey and then
destroy it there which that's also super
weird which is like i'm going to destroy
it what does it matter where i am yeah
no [ __ ] do it in jersey yeah jersey
strong yeah but you know you you don't
say no to kevin so
that was one of the weirdest ones i
think for sure
i uh
my my weirdest thing and it will mean
nothing to many of you but kevin asked
me to go to brooklyn
now brooklyn
is the weirdest well it's not the
set
new york city five boroughs manhattan
the cool one uh queen whatever um the
bronx the boogie down bronx that's where
rap came from also it's on fire most of
the time um
then there's brooklyn which is right
like kind of closer to manhattan a
little bit near queens but it's a
[ __ ] maze because brooklyn like
manhattan has a grid like a real city
does brooklyn no grid it's just like
somebody dropped spaghetti on a map and
said that's where the roads go yeah
and staten island is its own thing that
nobody talks about no it smells weird no
so kev's like um i'm shooting a movie
i'm shooting cop out in brooklyn do you
want to come to the set and i was like
yeah not because i want to go to sets
cause movie sets the first day you spend
on a movie set it's the most amazing
place in the world because it's a it's a
beast that's alive with making stuff and
everybody knows what they're doing and
it's chaos but it has an order to it
it's amazing the second day is like
watching paint dry yeah
it's the most boring place in the world
because most of it is waiting most of it
is like all right we're going to shoot
this scene we're going to do a take
great do we got it excellent we got to
move all of this [ __ ] to shoot the next
thing and moving all this [ __ ] takes
time even if it's literally like if
you're shooting two people talking all
of the lights are built to shoot that
person and then if you want to shoot the
reverse angle you have to move all of
the lights and sometimes it's you have
to move all of the trucks and half the
set so it just takes time it's a it's a
labor intensive process
and so i was like you want to come in
the set like yeah [ __ ] all right
whatever so i go hey trying to get to
brooklyn which i hate
um like i get lost nine times i finally
get there it's like nine o'clock at
night and it's dark and i want to be in
brooklyn at night because the [ __ ]
warriors will happen yeah man and
baseball fury is my guess both are going
to [ __ ] come out for me so i'm like
not going to [ __ ] brooklyn but i go
to brooklyn
and uh i finally make my way to set and
you know
which also takes some doing because i'm
just like a random black dude stumbling
upon a movie scene i'm like here you see
kevin smith and the odds of finding the
person who knows that i'm actually going
to see kevin smith
very slim yeah so i finally get there
and uh and they're shooting some scene
with like adam brody and uh and kevin
pollock and uh and kevin's doing his
thing and he's like directing and i'm
like alright cool this is i guess this
is fun and then uh then they just stop
and they wait and i'm like what's going
on is that while we're waiting for bruce
to show up
and uh
it's like all right [ __ ] bruce willis
and um
into the crew and just waiting like
they're all set up they move the lights
they're ready to go
and they're just waiting and so they
turn on
um in video villages says nothing but
monitors and the monitors will all show
everybody what's being shot so there's
like five or six like smallish flat
screen tvs and they just decide to tune
into the yankee game
because it's [ __ ] it's like a tuesday
night in brooklyn and what else are you
gonna do is they play a yankee game
and uh and so they do the thing that
they do i'm sure they do in hockey i
don't watch much hockey miyakopa but
every sports event will always do the
thing where it's like well let's see
who's at the game
and
uh so they're going around it's like
who's behind old played oh well there's
that guy and there's that legend and
there's whatever
hey right behind on play there's bruce
willis
and literally the entire crew is waiting
for him to show up
and the the pullback was he's stuck in
traffic and no he wasn't 200 teamsters
are like watching this dude watch a
yankee game just laughing drinking a
beer eating a hot dog
and so
and and then the set got dark
and it fell to tracy morgan to be like
this sort of light-hearted spiritual
puck of it and so tracy for reasons that
remain unclear to me had memorized
almost all of the original planet of the
apes
and was doing like a one-man rendition
of planet of all of planet of the apes
and like i think he'd been doing in
chunks so like by the time i got there
to witness it he was like towards the
end yeah and and
and just
it's a thing to watch [ __ ] tracy
morgan just lean into [ __ ] planet of
the apes
by himself yes
and doing all the voices yeah you know
like really well it's like you took this
planet that was a paradise and you made
a desert of it
like he's [ __ ] going for it and then
like you know half an hour later [ __ ]
bruce rolls up
he's like
hey guys you ready to shoot
yeah bruce
we're all ready to shoot and it was like
everybody everybody gave him the the
side eye that like okoye gives the hulk
in in avengers infinity war when she
sees him stumble in the in the
hulkbuster armor as you see
we're ready to shoot
um
that's the craziest place i ever went
for kevin smith brooklyn in the middle
of night for a crew full of teamsters
bruno was at the yankee game he's having
a blast decided to just knock off and
watch a ball game while they were making
a movie that
he was the star of and he was supposed
to be in brooklyn which is a good hour
away you know given traffic
okay
professional to the last none of what
you've said has been a lie professional
to the last
and gentlemen a new sponsor
is going to be exciting man
beyond where we've been previously
ladies and gentlemen and that new
sponsor
our second sponsor of the night second
half of the show the q and a part of the
show what most considered the best part
of the show
is sponsored god by the good folks at
shaker
and spoon what is shaker and spoon
you're asking man shaker and spoon is a
a
monthly club man where they send you
drink ingredients
and then you [ __ ] throw a party it's
fantastic i got these boxes delivered to
my house my wife took them through a
[ __ ] party for her friends upstairs
um they give you all the ingredients
every month you get a subscription box
has a bunch of ingredients with a bunch
of lists how to make your drinks and
stuff bam
you're sauced
i'm opening mine right now look at what
mark's doing right there man you provide
the booze they provide everything else
mark uh i everyone knows i'm not a
drinker man but my wife vouched for it
hardcore she took all that [ __ ] took it
all and met with her girlfriends and
that was great um i'm a smoker obviously
but you're a man who enjoys a drink
so
what's your take on shaker and spoon
let's hear it
well i'm opening up the box and you know
i one of the things that i did quite a
bit over the pandemic was was a
sort of food prep boxes like blue apron
and hello fresh and if i did not know at
the time that there was also a similar
service that offered you boots and not
just boost boots because you can boot
delivered any way you want but you know
it would give you the the recipe cards
and how to make the drink this is a
creole sling i got a homestead
old-fashioned
i've got a bacala
sour
all eyes on rye like this is a rye box
it's all about rye is your booze and you
open it up and they give you all of all
the ingredients what is this i don't
even know what this is
i got all this weird-ass packing [ __ ]
and then i got lemons i got cold brew
coffee
i got vermont maple syrup
everything i could possibly need to make
this happen
hell yeah
hell yeah you provide booze
you provide the booze they provide
everything else byob it's just like at
one of those catholic spaghetti dinners
byob ladies and gentlemen
but they shaker and spoon they're gonna
give you this monthly cocktail
subscription box that delivers the craft
cocktail experience right to your front
[ __ ] door you ain't got to go to the
bar bar's coming to you ladies and
gentlemen
yes
yes yes yes each box is themed around
one type of liquor this one was all rye
even better owning all 12 cocktails
should be exactly one bottle of liquor
so no waste at all
um shaker and spoon
introduces you to spirits and flavor
combinations you may have never
discovered otherwise ladies and
gentlemen you're going to be putting
some stuff in your booze you're like
what i think you're drinking and be like
oh
well where have you been all my life and
then you're going to wake up the next
morning be like what happened you're
going to wake up
shaker and spoon in somebody man because
[ __ ] this shit's this is a party for
heaven's sakes they give you all the
ingredients uh to mix fancy drinks i
remember when my when i was a kid
mark my parents would drink fancy drinks
they didn't they were not like i'll have
a glass of wine or you know give me a
[ __ ]
bourbon or something [ __ ] like my mom
was like uh i will have a pink squirrel
and my husband will have a green
grasshopper like they drank the
really froofy drinks and stuff like that
so my parents believed in this very this
mixology type of thing um i like that
your parents drink like power rangers i
will take drinks that are color-coded i
know it was adorable and as a kid a
youngster i was like can i have some
pink squirrel it's just a fun name and a
fun look
but it would not have been fun to
inebriate a child um so they didn't back
in the day
uh and neither will
the good folks here ladies and gentlemen
at shaker and spoon uh they want you
to get together with your friends and
have a good time man
uh putting together
clever new drinks that they're gonna
give you all the ingredients for every
month they're gonna put a party right
into your mouth
shake her
uh click the link below
might be there or uh just go to the
website man that's shaker and spoon
dot com slash fat man and they're gonna
give you 20 bucks off your first box
like not 20 off 20 off your first box
that's about it
make some drinks
and then [ __ ] hopefully next month
you're like bring it on i want more give
me more
i'm gonna have a party in my house i'm
tired of going outside yeah bring me the
party
party in your house and put a party in
your mouth with the good folks at shaker
and spoon ladies and gentlemen shaker
and spoon dot com slash fat man you go
there right now you use the code fat man
you're gonna get 20 bucks off your first
box we thank the good folks at shaker
and spoon man mark show them what you
got right one more time show them that
more time
i'll show you the whole box and look
lots of awesome packing material yeah
look at that material
enough it's a good [ __ ] it's a good box
it's good ingredients go ahead make
yourself some booze you like if you
don't like it you know the box next
month try something new he's wrong man
we thanked good folks at shaker and
spoon uh for sponsoring this year
program
um all right so i think we are going to
do
what i like to call what everybody likes
to call q a
um
if one has a question for either ming or
myself preferably for both of us but
either one will do um ask away we have
some posters here yeah we have
incentives just uh you know
just of ming and myself yeah we'll sign
them designed by the great and powerful
uh nate gonzalez dark knight returns who
does all the fat man beyond posters he
did a special custom for fan con poster
just for us and uh and so we will uh the
both of us will sign the the good
questions i'm gonna tell you what the
bad questions are yeah i love i'm
forever being the merciless which you
know if you know me at all like is not
you were the the most adorable person um
yeah i'm pretty merciful when you're all
things considered i felt a little bad
because like i didn't talk to nate about
it i was like if i did i would have said
don't do ming the merciless it's so easy
no it's perfect though yes but he also
knows i love flash gordon and so it's
it's
it's a [ __ ] it's a devil's trap yeah
so i i approve even though like i didn't
approve it
even though i don't like it yeah for
sure uh should we go left or right uh i
guess you're first so let's go right yes
hey man
hey man nice hey man apparently did you
write down your question
yeah were you nervous that you would
forget it yeah that's cool you can tilt
that mic up till the mic tilt it up a
little bit okay
anyway i love you guys how you doing are
you enjoying the con
you're very much so yeah this is uh this
is one of my favorites yeah well it's
got the alcohol on there so oh well
you know sir this is five percent this
is water in canada
i'll i'll try to be on brand uh
considering uh
the subject matter um
so i was gonna ask if you meaning both
of you obviously uh were given a blank
check to take the reins of any comic
franchise what would it be
and what would you do with it
any comic franchise
wow that's a tough one
yeah okay all right now i think i got to
answer you have an answer you want me to
go first you go first because you've
actually you've written you've written
some kind of
i the greatest part about what i do
because i meet people like oh comic like
they don't know what i do like so what
do you write or draw or like what do you
do i'm like no i don't do any of those
i'm i'm known for appreciating pop
culture and comics i it's great because
i need no talent at all like i like i
didn't write star wars i like star wars
and that's what i'm known for as a guy
who loves star wars like that's what i'm
known for so i will let you answer this
one first uh okay there uh there's a
comic book
that i love have love for a long time
called lone wolf and cub
um excellent and i will i will butcher
the names of i'm not gonna try and do
the names because listen i'm getting a
little nude yes and so i don't trust
myself to make it through japanese names
at the moment but it is a there's like
20 volumes of this thing
um this legendary piece of manga
literature that it's this massive story
about a executioner for a shogun who's
framed by a rival clan and uh and is
forced to go on the run
um with him and his infant son
and it's a it's a long tale of revenge
it's a long tale of of getting what you
think you're owed meanwhile also trying
to raise a child and and not letting him
die and your responsibility to that kid
it's it's wonderful it's beautiful does
this sound familiar by the way uh you
know they later kind of remade it into a
show called the mandalorian like
a little bit yeah
there's a little there's a lot of lone
wolf there's a ton a lone wolf in cub in
there um but it's it's gorgeous and it's
tragic and it's it's you know serene and
violent and
it is built for long-form storytelling i
i think that i am probably not the
person to do that because i don't have
much as i love it i feel like there's
probably some some hungry young japanese
screenwriter out there who can add and
fulfill all of the cultural
specificities i don't have a key into
but i would like to take that money and
empower that person to tell that story
and then take some of the credit for
hiring him
um or her um but yeah that's that's the
one that's the that's like the great
untapped joy that's built for prestige
tv that nobody's done yet
that's amazing um
i'm a huge fan of the mid 90s uh
relaunch of the starman franchise um who
james robinson james robinson yeah
and uh it follows the the the tale of uh
the original starman's son jack knight
who kind of is choose being a superhero
um
he wants no part of it uh but he's kind
of forced into the roles uh his his
brother was kind of taking on the man
who gets executed
and uh you know his dad's too old to
take on the manual and he decides he
wants to be the cool version of star man
like i'm not wearing the spandex i'm
gonna wear a leather jacket and he loves
he runs an antique store and he loves
old stuff
and uh he's like i'm not carrying this
cosmic rod because it looks like a sex
toy i'm gonna
i'm gonna do the kha'zix staff instead
and uh it's
it's one i think it's way underrated no
one ever talks about jack the jack
knight star man it's so good it's so
good it's it's ripe for either a tv
series possibly a movie but i mean
there's so many cool villains and and uh
you know ancelite characters in that i
think it'd be great a great tv series
and that's one i wish would just get way
more light on it because i think i mean
it really that one really spoke to me
i mean that's that's the same sort of
time as like why the last man and the
future and
it was really really like influential
yeah and important in that kind of mid
to late 90s boom of dc comics yeah oh
it's great and i just really love that
character it's like i'm not we're
black leather jacket yeah i know he went
to tank goggles and uh just a really
really cool character and no one ever
talks about the yeah the artist i think
by tim harris i believe
we're talking about it now yeah we are
man we're bringing we're bringing that
one back man hey man you should make
that into a show yeah but that one uh
yeah i i wish i don't know if anyone's
picked up any right circuits just out
there but that's one uh i i'm you know
i'm kind of searching like variety
please like to today let today be the
day that the jackknife star man gets
gets uh gets some attention and uh
hasn't come yet so eventually they'll
run out of stuff like hey what about
this one you should listen to ming yeah
didn't ming talk about that yeah
yeah but that one uh that one was a
scott mosher uh kevin's uh old producer
he's the one that that introduced me to
that one nice scott's a pretty cool dude
so
he's cooler than i am he's cooler than i
am too so [ __ ] scott mojo yeah for
sure yeah awesome man good question good
answers yeah very for sure here
i will tag this for you on my forum and
there's someone that has uh followed you
guys advice to find out what you love
and do it uh you guys are very
inspirational and i love both of you
guys thanks a lot
thank you come on
[Applause]
uh all right over there hello sir what's
your name uh george mchale george george
wellmed
good question yes um thanks for coming
to british columbia and uh my question
is more from mark uh
in master of the universe
revelation uh did you guys consider
including some of the characters such as
guild or blade uh saurod and karg that
were in like the masters of the universe
movie with like dolph lundgren was that
because i like those designs i think
they're pretty cool but they're not in
like the animated stuff um
i i will say
that part of the you know when you're
doing a show like master of the universe
there's when you're doing any show
that's based on ip or or toys or a book
or novel or whatever
there's like a fence you get to play in
and part of the fence we had to play in
with with revelations was the mattel
fence
like you know we had the stuff that they
had the toy rights too and but but we
couldn't really deal with some of the
things from the other adaptations of it
so the movie was one of those things
that was off limits for us because
mattel doesn't own it netflix doesn't
own it it belongs to whoever the [ __ ]
owns that
um i'll pretend it's like golden globe
is a cannon it feels like one of those
movies
it's cannons you could put them out a
bit there you go
um
so yeah it wasn't
it wasn't so much as we decided not to
do it it was more like well you know
here's here's what we know we can play
with and kevin had some characters that
he fundamentally was like this has to be
in there um teddy biaselly who's the
netflix exec championed this for years
and years was like he's got to be these
guys and then matilda was like you could
also have those guys um
i i did not have that much of a horse in
that race or a stake in that fight or a
or a dog in that hunt or any other um
aphorism that might lend itself to this
particular usage um because as i said
before i'm not that big a fan so i was
like we're gonna have human in it right
well about that
yeah it's like we're going to have a
cringer in it right yeah man in arms
yeah tealer yeah anybody else
so
you know basically it's like if i'm
putting together the all-star team i
just want to know the big hitters and
then tell me who the players to be named
later and then we'll we'll make them
cool
you got a poster too yeah and they go
hey they got stinkover in there what
more do you want
well
once you're like muse needs a roll
[Laughter]
stink or
sorry it takes me 10 minutes to set my
autograph
i always get so much crap from the other
guys
thank you sir
your question
gary public radio shout out oh thank you
man yes
uh my question for you guys is if you
could go back and experience any movie
again for the first time what movie
would it be
oh damn
um
you got an answer oh yeah for sure uh
summer in 1985 my dad takes me to the
mall we go to the movie theater and uh
it takes me to a little movie called
back to the future
and i was me and my brother and my dad
and i i knew nothing about it i didn't
even know why he took us he you know he
didn't take us to the movies but uh we
would usually go see james bond movies
and so i don't know what about that was
what um
convinced him to like we got to go
opening weekend to this movie and
i i remember you know opens up and he
goes back in time but i i remember
feeling really uncomfortable when george
was up in the tree and lorraine um uh
what uh leah thompson's taking off her
bra and i should feel uncomfortable yeah
i felt really good because i'm next to
my dad he was like what kind of movie is
this he's a [ __ ] sex criminal yeah
but you know and you know we all know
back to the future but i remember you
know the the little alarm clock goes off
at the end and
the car is dying and i remember feeling
so much stress and tension i was like
how is he gonna get back like it's not
gonna happen like i don't like
everything's gonna work right and the
thing came unplugged
and like all this stuff and i just the
range of emotions that that movie takes
especially as a 10 year old
am i also a pervert yeah i know yeah
no i was bird watching dad i was i was
watching birds
i was bird watching
um but then yeah
you know he makes it back and and
everything's good and then to be
continued like everything about that
movie was like as a ten-year-old's like
i don't know i just awoke
everything and i don't know if i've ever
felt like that again ever watching uh
watching a movie and um
yeah i mean so much so i'll see if i can
roll this up but um
but uh you know later on you know years
years later i got this [ __ ] pastor
tattoo
uh my arm
and um deep love
yeah for sure
uh but yeah i just remember just sitting
in theater as the credits roll like holy
[ __ ] like that
like movies can do this like they can
it yeah i i probably haven't felt that
since star wars when i was four years
old in 1977 so
and i don't know
i don't know if i felt that like that
again maybe you know end game maybe um
there's a good one yeah like watching
part of my pandemic survival kit was
watching audios reactions to endgame on
youtube
like when i just needed to oh yeah how
crazy is that yeah
why is everything awful and why am i
dying inside and then i just oh god the
hammer lifted who's it going oh [ __ ] and
then just watching the audience lose
their [ __ ] minds and you're left yeah
like that's so great the warm hug that i
needed like every three days
for four months
[Laughter]
um i this is a really difficult question
to answer because i i
there are so many like in game would be
one of them
um
mad max fury road is one of them
i'm just like i didn't know you could do
this and like why are not everybody
that's on the screen dead because i'm
sure they killed like dozens of stuntmen
doing this [ __ ]
like it's it's a movie that should not
exist at that level but yet does and
it's wonderful
um
the matrix i remember being in the
theater for the matrix yeah
and like nobody knew what it was like if
you went opening weekend
nobody [ __ ] knew and the the trailers
were just literally what is the matrix
you just have to see it for yourself
it's in the [ __ ] movie
right it became the tagline yeah but in
the trail yeah that was it just the
green like the computer text and that
was there what is the matrix like all
right keanu saying i guess i'll go see
this sure like
it looks close kung fu in it that looks
bad
um but the thing that that that that
immediately came to mind was and it's
easy for us
at this age with this much room remove
to forget how big a [ __ ]
plot twist it was
in terminator 2
when [ __ ] spoilers get out 30 years
old when arnold is the good guy
you know because we have been
conditioned as a culture
by that point that he's the terminator
he's evil he cannot you cannot stop him
whatever you do will find her no matter
what you do it's it's what he does all
he does and
to be in that theater you know it must
have been whatever [ __ ] like 17 18
years old and 1992 yeah so like opening
[ __ ] night you know in a one screen
movie theater on long island that was
massive it was like the ziegfeld of long
island but
uh which are two references and you
don't get it all but awesome theater
um
and to get to that moment when arnold is
walking down the hall with a [ __ ] box
full of roses and [ __ ] john connor's
in the middle and then robert patrick is
on the other end and arnold pulls the
[ __ ] shotgun out of the box of roses
you're like he's going to kill a [ __ ]
kid i hope that cop gets to him
and then you know [ __ ] starts
unloading on the cop and then like this
get down yes he's like come with me if
you want to live like
that was
the plot twist to end all [ __ ] plot
twists
and to feel that in the movie there now
feel that energy of everybody no longer
understanding the movie they were
watching but down for it for real
it's like that's the [ __ ] that makes one
hey want to be a movie fan and b want to
try and make movies is to get an
audience to pull an audience to a place
where they belong to you
and then to [ __ ] with them so
supremely yeah and destroy what they
thought they were going to get but then
give them something better
it's like
i we under underestimate the tonnage of
that plot twist and what it meant at the
time and it's still it's one of my
favorite in-theater experiences yeah now
in 2021 there's no way they could have
kept that a secret you can't absolutely
not i mean it's the way they kept i mean
so much of the end game [ __ ] is a secret
like it still boggles the mind but like
they had to do all kinds of [ __ ]
chicanery and that scene was all shot
indoors in a [ __ ] warehouse somewhere
but
yeah it's it
it's similar i think to
um
the red wedding in game of thrones
you know in that the thing that that
that still it gives me faith in humanity
is that
hundreds of thousands of people read
those books and knew what was coming
and then didn't tell anybody
but
i wanted to watch their friends watch it
because they
so like a culture kept a secret which it
almost never [ __ ] does in the edge of
the internet and spoilers and everything
but the sadistic joy people took like
of like well let's watch this episode
it's gonna be a wedding it's gonna be
fun everybody's gonna get like there's
gonna be cake and songs
and then suddenly their phones would
come out as they're like watching you
watch it like they're videotaping me oh
nothing i'm just checking my email
making sure my camera cleans
and that that giddy glee of watching
hearts break like
that that makes me feel better
here yeah t2 is my answer back to the
future is his answer um excellent
question um and you signed in advance i
did i didn't want to take everybody i
only got you know we only got a couple
hours so do you real quick do you have
one
uh i would actually uh it's kind of a
stereotypical one but i would go back
and i would watch uh the a new hope
because i was it was one of my mom's
like favorite movies and so i didn't see
it until the re-release of theaters and
she took me
and she
i remember turning over and watching her
like smiling at me watching this movie
and when the death star blew up i full
on freaked out because it was the
coolest effect i'd ever seen
and it was i there was like a just a
really
warm fuzzy happy feeling attached to
that yeah i i have used i i've more than
once in more than one writer's room i've
said we want this to feel like screaming
out of the sun to blow up the death star
like that's the moment we should be
feeling of like the hero that we thought
was gone he's come back out of the
[ __ ] sun and to just give us the all
clear kid just blow this thing go home
yeah like that's that is my favorite
moment
in movies period that's awesome thank
you guys so much thank you man
yeah real quick you have you have two
kids i have two kids how old are they 19
and 17. all right so when they were
growing up did you the star wars movies
did you show them what order did you
show them star wars on did you go four
five six oh yeah one two three four five
six one two three and then you know at
some point you get the seven eight nine
okay you're a good parent that's what
i'm trying to yeah yeah yeah there's
there's no come on okay i'm just i was
just checking what am i a communist no
no not at all
yeah
i was a test you passed excellent thank
you
yes your question
um
my question is about
um where do you think um batman fits in
the
uh ensemble world of the justice league
when when i was watching
um
the last the zack snyder version
um
great version and he was a bigger part
of the world but it feels like it's a
world filled with super um humans and
gods
and then there's batman who is great
leader batman is so important to me as a
as a child like that was the
standard and he feels a little bit
um relegated to
the
um logistics guy and
and i would have loved to see ben
affleck do more with the like he's
amazing and he can do anything so where
does he fit in the
ensemble world of
of dc
uh do you have a feeling
i'm
i i don't even know where they're taking
him i mean dc is
so
disjointed
and uh and you know in the batman the
robbers pens and batman movies coming up
but that's that's not anywhere in that
same universe so right i have no idea
where they're going with this i mean
batman's a challenge you know because
the in in in
in bad hands and in
ill-tempered hands he's hawkeye right
like he's like yeah
and like i don't mean to give hawkeye
[ __ ] but come on he's hawkeye
um like if anybody should have died to
save the world it probably should have
been [ __ ] hawkeye right right
yeah i'm just saying yeah yeah no one
would have really missed him
yeah you know but like marvel has done
better in figuring out how to use their
like captain america is just an olympic
athlete like with a little you know jews
who's got like yes his shield is [ __ ]
bulletproof but he's just a guy tony
stark just a guy just smart and rich
what's your superpower i'm rich tony
stark is the antithesis of that
but batman is the original version right
and so
the comic books especially written by
people like you know either mark wade or
grant morrison or jeff johns like people
understand him have figured out how to
use batman as
both um the giant brain
of the of the justice league like he's
the one who thinks of all this [ __ ]
because he's smarter than everybody else
um he pays for everything like sure um
but the thing that makes him separate is
his will
right like there is no quit in batman
period um and so how you make that
fundamental to your story is the
challenge and the problem with the
movies is hey you've gotten seven
characters to serve
and that's not a lot of time to dig deep
into any one of them
and b you're you you then become it
becomes a speed race of like how fast
can we get this plot because we've got
these seven characters we've got our
villain plot we've got whatever
emotional stuff we're gonna get between
them there's no time for deduction
there's no real time for planning
there's no time for that stuff and so
then it's just a dude with a belt who's
got some gadgets on it yeah which was a
cool car and a cool car which suddenly
makes them feel underpowered compared to
gods who can punch holes through planets
so some of it is is the format you know
and some of it is also like maybe
batman's just a guy who was meant to
play alone and he doesn't play that well
with others and so to give him the heft
and the weight like his world is
different than superman's world is
different than cyborg's world it's
different in the green lantern's world
and to butt them all together makes it
feel weird um
you know marvel has solved this problem
a bunch of different times a bunch of
different ways mostly through tone
right like the marvel movies um the tone
of them is always fun so suddenly when
you put thor in a movie with captain
america it doesn't feel that weird
because the tone is right it doesn't
feel like you're you know playing
[ __ ] death metal and here's a dude
playing power ballads like oh no we're
all playing the same song it's just
different musicians on the same scale
you know and so then you get guardians
which is just [ __ ] like weird ass
power pop right and then
then you get you know [ __ ] ant-man
which is just some doing a piccolo in
the corner just [ __ ] playing this
little jumpy song yeah but it fits in
somehow somehow it all fits in because
the tone
you're all playing the same song with
different instruments where dc feels
like it's playing all the songs at once
and so it kind of ends up being noise
that never works out it never works out
so it's just a matter i think of dc
figuring out like are we doing this
multiverse anymore are we doing these
group things anymore are we building a
team or are we just telling these
one-off stories or these these isolated
character stories that feel good you
know we'll see what flash
slash flashpoint is and how they managed
to blend all those things but
um it's a hard nut to crack and and dc
hasn't really done it well um i hope
they find a way because i want a good
justice league movie but you've got to
be able to see what all what songs all
these instruments want to play and can
you get them on the same [ __ ] page
because right now it's very much like
not my tempo
not my tempo
it's like great enough i never heard it
compared to music and bands it's a great
analog it's a really good analogy thank
you i just made it up wow
wow canada man you're you're being
inspired by the uh the great white north
uh it's all brought to you by nude
yes vodka soda yes
it lubricates the brain thank you sir
that's a great yeah but i think oh yeah
in the end we just want good we want a
good batman movie we want a good justice
league movie we want yeah totally just
and give me a [ __ ] good song yeah and
wonder wonder 184 what the hell was that
[Music]
i
can you explain that you're a writer in
your video
how did that even happen did no one be
like dude this is awful like what are
you doing like somewhere early in the
process or were they like yeah we'll let
them do whatever they want and then like
oh my god i don't know it's like every
time you're making a thing it's very
much far's for the trees and when you're
in the middle of it it's hard to see all
of it
and maybe they just didn't have that
person who could be like hey gang just
looking at it objectively yeah i don't
know what this is yeah and this also
feels like
icky yeah and like where'd this plane go
and where'd it come from and why are you
flying a jet and what what and love okay
sure didn't you steal that dude's body
okay okay yeah i guess that works like
no it's
hi
what's your name michelle welcome
michelle thank you well first uh thanks
for coming to northern fancon it's
awesome to have you guys both here um
you've been
i'm here for the ketchup chips
ketchup chips cheesies uh it's all on my
table
i gotta get my hands on some ketchup
chips all right get somebody get mark
some ketchup chips tomorrow all you
gotta do is add that for you that's what
i do and look at you should see my table
right now
it looks like uh yeah the shopper's drug
mart blew up in there are you like the
milton berle of chips
i don't have his girth but you've got
the length
if you don't know the story milton below
once upon a time no it was sid caesar um
we had a a kids show
and he said hey kids
today what i'd like you to do is go in
your parents wallet get a dollar and
send it to sid caesar's care of cbs
studios
just as a [ __ ] joke yeah and millions
of dollars showed up
and they were like you can't do that
anymore you can't just steal money from
the populist sid caesar
so like i sort of feel like me saying
you know what i really like ketchup
chips and suddenly i've got like 98 bags
of ketchup chips it works it works it
works
yes so
yeah lays old dutch you'll take all of
them so [ __ ] yeah give me that sweet
salt [ __ ] oh yeah you're questioned so
you guys have both been to a lot of
conventions yeah um a memorable
experience that you can tell us about
oh man
huh
um well i mean so last week i was at in
salt lake city it's a pretty big con
they're very well budgeted and they get
huge guests so
i get to my table to set up and i look
to the left and right of me to the left
i got christopher eccleston the ninth
doctor to my right i got ashley eckstein
uh voice of ahsoka tenno i'm like so
they put me between a doctor and a jedi
like how can i compete with this it was
a really weird placement and i was like
geez i felt about this big because
i could you know how do you compete with
a doc like a legit doc the ninth doctor
and
you know a jedi twice over and and
rebels and clone wars and um
yeah so you know they had these huge
lines you know i got a couple people but
yeah so i changed my strategy i was like
i'm just going to talk to all the people
in the other two lines and get them to
come over afterwards so it's it it sort
of worked but
yeah but
yeah but i think for me you know like
like i said i'm just known for being a
nerd like i didn't create anything i'm
not here because i'm talented i'm just
here because i you know because i worked
for kevin and i really kind of felt ass
backwards in all of this uh i remember i
was at a con and uh negan had just been
introduced
and
jeffrey d morgan was at the con
and i i saw he was outside smoking and i
really really wanted to meet him but i
was you know it's an intimidating
character
i've never met him and i was like do i
go up to him should i go say hi to him
and finally i just got you know i i got
the nuts and i was like i'm just gonna
go say hi so i go up to a real nervous
like hey hey sir my name is ming um i'm
on the show comic book man that comes on
after yours uh
i'm a really big fan you're awesome he's
like dude ming i watch your show like
i love your show i and i was like whoa
what the hell
he's like yeah and he starts rattling
specific points from the show like oh
man i saw that show where ralph macchio
came in he taught you to wax on waxar
properly he was like that was awesome
man i was like holy [ __ ] like papi
winchester
knows who i am he watches the show it
just blew me away that you know that
and it never occurred to me that maybe
he watches the show after his
and and
and maybe became a fan of it and i was
like holy crap and you know you know
even now but at the time he was probably
like one of the biggest stars on the
planet just because of
the the negan persona
and uh
yeah it just never hit me that like
these big stars could maybe watch some
of them might watch what i do and and
possibly like it and i thought that was
i thought that was pretty cool
um
hmm
i'm gonna i'm gonna give you three of
them
um the first is i was at a convention in
in london
about five years ago
and two things happened that were
remarkable to me the first was
benedict cumberbatch was a guest
and john cleese was a guest and benedict
cumberbatch lost his [ __ ] [ __ ] over
getting to meet john cleese
which reminded me that everybody is a
fan of somebody and everybody gets to
feel this way when they get to finally
meet the person that has met the most to
them you know and sometimes that person
is you know a politician or a world
leader or a sports athlete whatever but
if you're in the arts if you're a
performer then everybody's got that
other actor that other person especially
if they're british especially if they
were part of your childhood
and like cumberbatch was legit like
crying to meet john cleese wow i was
just like this is the most amazing thing
i've ever seen
and that same convention was a
convention that i overheard trisha
helfer tell somebody i i'm i haven't
seen battlestar since it aired and i
think i'm going to do a re-watch and
then i from the corner shout out if
that's true that's a podcast
um and then it became a podcast yeah
like yeah you let you become a podcast
that's great the battlestar galactica
which we wrapped last year like mid
pandemic where we watched every episode
of battlestar together um
you know like great things can happen at
[ __ ] conventions um the second thing
is
um
i was
i was in san diego
um san diego comic-con
and i went to entertainment weekly
throws a party every year
and it is like
it's the party to get into and i worked
for the magazine so i was able to get
into it but it's really [ __ ] tough
and it began to be this magnet for stars
and i'm at this party i'm like not
hammered but
like you know the nail is like this deep
in like i'm not flush with the wood yet
but i'm working on it and then nathan
phillian walks in
and i was like oh [ __ ]
all right
all right am i drunk enough to go and
roll up on captain mouse like i think i
might be
and so i walk up to it's like hey listen
i just want to say i really like your
work
um i work for the magazine but i'm also
brown code
and like
and this the the look on his face went
from like just another [ __ ] schmuck i
gotta meet at a party to like
oh yeah all right
let me here's my brother let's talk
about [ __ ] let's hang out for like an
hour and a half and let's just [ __ ]
jaw it up
but and that's that's kind of when i
fell in love with him
he doesn't know this
um or maybe he does because i've never
been shy about it but
he he was the sweetest man because i
hear you build them this way in canada
um
but my favorite con memory ever it was
it was early in my san diego run um i've
now gone for 20 years almost in a row
and this must have been like the third
or fourth that i went to
and i was walking the floor as i want to
do at a convention
and i saw this cluster this gaggle of
teenagers
um
uh just sort of like
find each other in a weird way like some
of them had been friends a couple
weren't it was clear
but they were all
very excitedly signing to each other
and it then occurred to me that like
this was a bunch of deaf kids who found
each other on this floor
who
clearly were drawn by something to san
diego because of their love for
something
and
it's the the the thread that connects
this community is that passion
and the comic con every comic-con is
about finding your people and sharing
that love with those people and it had
never occurred to me until that moment
and absolutely should have
that those people are every people you
know and that there are you know
disabled people and blind people and
deaf people and black people and white
people and chinese people and mexican
you know people people and everybody has
a thing that they love
and this is a place you can find that
and it just and and i now look for that
every convention i go to just that
moment of connection of people finding
each other joined by the thing that they
love
and so that that was a very deep lesson
for me of what the power of places like
this and the the value of places like
this because we the world can be
divisive in so many ways and the only
thing that actually cleaves us together
is the things that we love and to see a
place that is founded and built on that
love um it just makes me feel better so
that's that's my favorite moment that's
cool man that's what concert all about
man
that's what khan's all about
i i thought of one more real quick if i
may i went to a convention over new
year's eve a couple years ago
and the headlining uh event
at this con was uh they invited stan lee
out his birthday was over that new
year's eve holiday i think his
birthday's on december 30th and they're
like okay we're going to do a stanley
birthday roast i'm like oh cool this is
awesome so the night of the roast about
two hours before i'm leaving and they're
like hey man you're coming into the
roast i'm like hell yeah dude
when when are we gonna see this and
they're like no no no no we want you on
the roasting panel
i'm like what i'm like you couldn't have
told me this a week ago so i could
prepare you know because it's it's tough
i don't know if you ever roasted anyone
i never have it's it's you know you not
only have to roast the the the man of
honor the woman of honor you have to
roast all the other people on the panel
and those are pretty heavy hitting
panels michael rooker
sean gunn ming na wen
uh the marissa lamar the two voices of
pinky in the brain
um
a couple other people and i'm like i'm
like if you yeah i'll do it but
i don't know how good i'm gonna give me
two hours to prepare so i went to dinner
i'm furiously trying to write jokes and
how do you roast stan lee like arguably
the nicest man on the planet but
um and then they made me go first
i just set the table i'm like crap so
but i came up with a couple of good
roasts for stanley uh one
um
he had i was doing a panel and he came
up he kind of crashed the panel
and i was on there i was just a
moderator but he comes up to me he's
like what you've done for comics is is
amazing you know everything your art you
know you've changed the world
and you're amazing and he left and like
wait wait a minute did he think i was
jim lee
[Music]
he thought it was jim lee and i am like
listen okay so during the road i called
him out on that i basically called him a
racist
[Laughter]
well all of us asians do look alike sure
sure i know like dude if you want to
mistake me for jim lee by all means
go ahead just you know i i need his you
know his paycheck too so dude used to
have two lamborghinis so
yeah the first time i met stan was at a
party at comic con
and uh and jim lee introduced us he was
like hey do you want do you want to meet
stan yeah it's like [ __ ] yeah i want to
be stanley let's go do this [ __ ] yeah
and so jim walks me over and he's like
hey uh hey it's uh it's it's stan and
stan was like it's the end of the night
he's tired so he stands up he [ __ ]
you know gets his his salesman on he's
like hi i see you've met jim no relation
it's like oh you beautiful old man yeah
yeah it's the ultimate ball buster but i
think my favorite thing was uh ming na
white you know i had to you know you
make fun of everybody awesome and and we
got to make now one i was like you know
ming now
you're amazing he's like listen i'm just
gonna lay it all out there i've had a
crush on you since joy luck club and you
know you've been in all these other
movies and i'm just gonna say it i would
love to get down with you you know
you're beautiful i i love you but it'd
be really weird screaming out my own
name in the bedroom so so i'm not going
to do it and yeah yeah so
nice yeah yeah so i basically told her i
want to have sex with her in front of
like 3 000 people
that's that's quite all right yeah and
she still says hi to me when i say hi
back when i see her so i guess she
thought it was funny so i you know
hopefully so she did the same thing to
mary mcdonald once you told me you want
to get down at another party i was a
little bit nude
booze
and i was like listen
if it's impre it's i i need to check
with my wife
but
if it's okay with her you could totally
come live with us and she was like
that's adorable
see you later
back to where this is cool though it's
cool
it's cool we just respect you deeply hey
you miss a hundred percent of the shots
you don't take michael scott wayne
gretzky
amen thank you great question thank you
yes your question hello
so we're at a convention so i think this
is appropriate what toy or collectible
from your childhood would you love to
have again and
maybe what toy or collectible that you
see at a convention nowadays would you
love to
have oh man that could be like an iron
man suit der hansel and carbonite
replica of the enterprise i don't know
so i got the one that i but i wanted for
30 years uh if you watch comic book men
a huge g.i joel fan
never i i moved to this new neighborhood
when i was nine all the kids were in the
he-man oddly enough and i i just i could
not relate to he-man because there was a
big muscular white dude with a bowl
haircut wearing fuzzy underwear i'm like
i'm never going to be this guy he's got
a green tiger like i was like i'm never
going to be this guy the tiger was the
lion
yeah all of this is achievable without a
[ __ ] tiger yeah cause i remember
going into their house i'm like what the
hell is this like this he-man man ours
ram man like i can't relate to these
guys but then i discovered g.i jones
like at least they got quick kick and i
think i think yeah you know snake guys
is asian i think storm showers they got
some asian dude so and you know these
guys are fighting uh uh uh enemy once
took over the world at the cold war
they're basically you know russians i
could relate to this so
um so i got huge into gi joe um vehicles
i actually ended up turning the whole
neighborhood they all threw their
he-mans in the in the storage bin and we
all went gi joe and i was like an
influencer in 1983 before you know
instagram or whatever
uh but a year 1983-84 i remember opening
up the little
catalog you got in the when you bought a
vehicle and it would show you what was
coming out the next year and in that
catalog was a seven foot aircraft
plastic aircraft carrier
built to scale for the figures called
the uss flag
i was like holy [ __ ]
what what like what this what is this
it's you know the aircraft carrier like
and when you're a kid you want the
biggest thing that exists out there
and at the time even now i think it's
one of the biggest toys ever made um
also one of the most expensive uh if you
account for inflation and stuff it was
one of the first toys to go for a
hundred dollars
and i i wanted this thing bad and i
begged my mom and dad
daily
um but they were like you know in a
world where the gi joe figure was maybe
three dollars
um you know 100 aircraft carrier was a
jump um and it was you know this thing
was truly a rich kids toy for two
reasons one it was very expensive
two you needed a freaking mansion with
another room to just house the toy in
so yeah my mom basically told me like
you're never gonna own this thing she
bailed the flight out told me that i
tried the trick was like you don't have
to buy me a christmas or birthday
present for the next 25 years
didn't yeah it didn't work so i never
got that and to add insult to injury
the kid who lived behind me who i hated
because he was a jerk
his parents had just gotten divorced oh
so for that christmas
he totally got it he got two of them oh
yeah
yeah
you know his parents were trying to buy
his life so his dad bought it for him
and and i remember he called me he was
like i got it i was like oh god that
that that [ __ ] got my dream toy
so i came over he let me put the
stickers on and [ __ ] but you know i'm
the whole time i was like you
freaking
i was just muttering under my breath but
then lately about 30 years later to the
day it came in on comic book men
and um
guy
gave me what i thought was a good price
for it um it was five and a half times
more expensive
in whatever 2013 than it was in 1983.
but uh yeah i finally i bought it um
and uh
yeah i mean i don't i don't know if
that's a story redemption i use my comic
book money to buy it so listen you got
that really a story of redemption or
yeah i mean i don't know if that's like
a hero was like oh my god he got his
just too but dude you know he uses
freaking tv money to buy a to buy a
vintage toy you got your rosebud man
don't [ __ ] i did you did yeah who you
are yeah although later on so i was like
oh man i'm going to take it home and set
it up show my kids it was awesome i was
like then i was like i have no room for
this like i still don't have a mansion
i'm still not like the rich kid and so
it sat in the basement in the store
unassembled for a while and i remember
one night i came into the store
and all of a sudden magically on the
back table it was assembled again i was
like what the [ __ ] did some magic elves
come in and reassemble this not a magic
elf jason music coming in the store
overnight saw it became obsessed with it
decided he needed to put it back
together again and left without telling
anybody
so
holy [ __ ] yeah so it kind of sat there i
was going to put in storage and i didn't
know what to do with it and um this dude
came in he was like hey man are you
selling that i'm like listen i don't
want to but i'll listen you know i'm a
businessman i'll listen to any offer
he's like i'll tell you what i'll give
you this much and i'm opening a brewery
down the street i'll give you free beer
for life if you sell it to me
and i'm like listen if i drink enough
beer i can make money off of this like
this this is a pretty unique offer and
he gave me the whole thing he's like
listen i'm buying i'm a big gi girl fan
my kid's a big giant fan like you can
come over and see it whenever you want
but free beer i'm like all right done so
and and now we're really good friends
now he's a sponsor of the podcast studio
that i've opened and actually kind of
worked out so you win so my new goal now
is to get one but in box
and that's going to be tough because
those run about 15 20 grand now
but i want that thrill i want to be
taken back to 1983 ming chen
christmas
and i want to open that thing up
you know granted i will have enough fu
money that i can drop 20 grand on an
unopened uss flag and have that
experience of setting it and of you know
just freshly opened smell that 1983 air
in the box like take the little missiles
out of the plastic trees put it on the
the the stickers like this will happen
one day i just don't know when but this
will happen fair enough yeah
do you have a toy mine mine is also uh
it's a ship
my favorite thing as a kid and i'm a
star wars kid um
was they used to have a millennium
falcon action figure holder like was the
case
but like you just it was the [ __ ]
falcon right and you'd crack it open and
there was a slot for each dude and
[ __ ] two had a thing a place to go
i think it made noise but you know
probably not i just didn't i brought all
the noises myself
um
and i remember
um
we we moved when i was like 10 years old
we moved from a house in the bronx to
long island we moved from we'd moving on
up to the suburbs
and
my mom
like torched half my [ __ ] room in the
move like just things she didn't think i
needed no because you're a big boy now
and you don't need these childhood you
know we put away our childhood things
and it got lost in the move i don't know
if it was intentional she says it wasn't
but i have my i have my theories
um
but i just i had such love for that and
so much love for star wars and i would
like i would i would sundo would clip
[ __ ] like the boxes off a cheerio
yeah send away for the kenner your prize
to get the ice croth yeah i saw han solo
and the [ __ ] winter outfit all that
[ __ ] i would do um so i kind of feel
like i don't have any more star wars
figures
but i would like to get that [ __ ]
falcon back
um
as for a new thing that i want
um
[Music]
i want a lightsaber
i mean which one i just want a really
[ __ ] i want a working lightsaber do
we have that yet oh yeah they're they're
working on it yeah they're working tell
me when they get like the working
lightsabers what would you do with said
lightsaber what are you are we cutting
wood with it like what do you
i would do everything good point okay i
would open mail with it i would make
toast with it i would like open garage
doors that were stuck with it i would
like carve my way into horses when i'm
chilly with it
like there's nothing you can't do with a
functional lightsaber you know except
for maybe butter your toast that you
made with your lightsaber because the
butter melts on the edge it's hard to
get a good smear yeah with a lightsaber
um
but yeah i mean
if i could have a thing you know what i
want i want um a full-size
uh star wars video game cabinet
coin up the one you could [ __ ] sit in
remember that [ __ ] yeah
you're talking about the vintage ones
from the 80s right with the vector
graphics yeah because i wanted to be the
kid from silverspoon i wanted to be
ricky oh man yeah i had [ __ ] video
games in his house and it was a bedroom
yeah [ __ ] bedroom that [ __ ] was dope
and so i kind of want one i'm never
gonna get one because i'm married and my
[ __ ] wife is gonna be like yeah let's
give a whole room to your big ass dumb
video game
put it next to ming's aircraft carrier
like yeah
yeah um but basically it's
your entire life is a is a way to sort
of recapture your childhood um nine
times out of ten you do that through
children one time out of ten you do that
through like ill-gotten gains where you
buy the [ __ ] you never got to have no um
so i got one done but let me get some
[ __ ] video game action working i'm
just saying
um thank you for your great here yeah
great question all right last question
of the night
we have our last question answer ask her
gosh pressure's on the pressure's on
don't [ __ ] it up not at all no yeah well
don't [ __ ] it up i mean we won't judge
you
no
um so we've heard what you wish you
could re-see for the first time for a
movie
uh i want to know if you could un-watch
something if you hated it so much what
would it be
oh man that's a great question
if i could take from these eyes a thing
that it is seen
i mean immediately comes to mind so uh i
think when the episode one trailer came
out um
they they did a thing where they're like
hey if you watch these certain movies
we'll play it in the beginning
and then we'll play it at the end and i
was like all right what movie do i have
to sit through
and i think one of them was wing
commander
and so the the beginning like the
episode one trail was great it's you
know after so like that drought of star
wars seen the pod racing and all that oh
it was it looked like it was awesome
so like i need to see that again so i
just sit through
freaking wing commander i can't remember
who was in like josh hartnett or
something mark hamill that's right mark
cam that's right
because i did the same [ __ ] thing did
you really need her to go see it no
we dipped out of work i was working in
manhattan at the time yeah just
literally walked to some 342nd street
that wasn't showing porn and we're like
when when is [ __ ] star wars showing
they're like it's not showing no
wing commander they're like oh well ten
minutes great
and uh and yeah we didn't last for the
second showing of the trailer
well really because i did cause that was
so i was like i'll sit through this
garbage to watch to watch that trailer
again because it was yeah it was awesome
man wow and unfortunately the movie was
not so awesome but
yeah
um a movie i wish i could unsee
um
this movie is probably not as bad as i
remember it it's just awful in the
context
which is indiana jones
and the kingdom of the crystal skull
no you're right which is
it's not like the worst movie ever made
it's just
leave me these first three
like let me let me live in a world in
which i didn't have to see that one and
this was just my cycle
you know again like i've i've seen worse
movies
but i've i've you know like i would also
like to not have those second two matrix
movies because what the [ __ ] was that
all about yeah you made one perfect
movie and then those things sure but you
know it's not
there's something to take away from
every movie that i see um sometimes it's
educational sometimes it's just
emotional sometimes it's whatever
but like
don't [ __ ] with glory
like jesus like i'm trying it hard i'm
finding it hard to find a steeper cliff
that
that a series has fallen off of than
crystal skull
so yeah just for my own happiness
like
i i there was some peter greenway movie
i think i saw like the cook the thief
his wife and her lover that i'm like i
don't need to see this what the [ __ ] is
that that was garbage don't want it
don't need it
um
but no [ __ ] crystal skull man
yeah
again like did no one be like i don't
know about this like i read this i don't
know like you know stephen
right here with the monkeys and the
vines
i don't know about this maybe yeah bro
what's with the fridge dude yeah you
just sparked a memory uh the third
matrix uh the revolutions i don't know
if you remember this they decided to
release it at the same time worldwide so
it'd be you know like
noon in the uk which was and in the east
coast where i was it was coming at 9 00
a.m
and
god bless my wife this is why i married
her i dragged her to the movie theater
at 9 00 am to watch matrix
revolution 9 a.m dude on the day it came
out because i thought it was like the
other one sucked though this one would
be awesome and it was even worse and uh
yeah that's love
it is or it's a legally binding contract
right i mean yeah if she was like listen
it's over after that i would have
totally understood that like i get it
this was abusive yeah
yeah i mean the other one that comes to
mind we talked about wonder woman 84. i
remember watching it i was like oh my
god i remember pausing it because i wat
it was i watched on whatever hbo max
it's like how much time is left in the
on in this movie it's an hour and 20
minutes we're still left i'm like you
got to be kidding me
an hour and 20 minutes
please just end my misery but i made it
to the end that's harsh it was yeah
yeah you know usually movies are you
know pretty well paced and and yeah an
hour and 20 minutes we're still left i
was like oh my god wow yeah yeah and i'm
gonna stick with crystal skull that's a
that's a good one that's a good one
um excellent question what's yours what
do you wish yeah do you have one uh
i guess it's the american with george
clooney i think it was the worst film
i've ever seen in my life
wow yeah well
yeah
it does not do a lot of things and my
tastes i've been told are pretty lacks i
can watch trash and enjoy it but that
one
yeah that's rough
that's rough you know like the one movie
that i remember seeing
that i was like listen i love sean
connery
i will watch anything sean connery's in
and then i watch zardoz
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] is going on here
like none of it made sense and like i i
was probably like 23 or 24 years old and
like i thought i knew some [ __ ] about
[ __ ] and then i was like
who paid for this like what's he wearing
what what's the giant head floating
doing and like
i i don't know if it's good or not i
just know that i have then stopped the
rule of i'll watch anything that actor
does because i love him because
sometimes you end up with zargaz yes
yeah yeah i mean
[ __ ]
i don't blame you i mean you had to
you you you had to see what it was you
know maybe it gets better maybe no it
doesn't watch the end maybe it's going
to make some sense yeah nope nope just
going to be this oh i just thought of
another one uh highlander two the
quickening oh
come on
yeah i i you know highlander awesome
like one of my top five movies almost a
perfect movie like you know every just
immortals like you know there's one
sanchez villalobos ramirez
yeah i remember and uh yeah i had to get
to the theater so like dad
will you take us he's like i'll come in
and watch it with you
don't do that
and yeah yeah and i'm like what the what
planet zeiss like what the hell is going
on here it
it like nothing there's nothing good
about that movie and it ruined
it oh it pretty much ruins the first
movie
you know if you if you even if you give
it any credence or if you even
acknowledge its existence
and uh yeah i remember my dad being so
disappointed in me that i made i dragged
him there and made him watch that and
that i'm right you out of the wheel ming
i know what you just did here i had such
high hopes for that movie though i'm
like okay they've built this great
universe like you know where all right
where they're gonna take it next like
how how awesome is this going to be
and like there were others
there's so much wrong with that movie so
much it was so
it was it was one of the most
disappointing days of my life i think
watching that holy [ __ ]
and then then i remember that okay they
came with a renegade cut i'm like oh man
maybe this is better and it's it's not
it's not it's not
no no well i mean the snyder cut had to
come from somewhere yeah yeah yeah but
yeah this it's not much easier you just
brought up uh yeah i had forgotten about
that movie until you just brought it up
so thanks my pleasure
thanks i wasn't you it's her yeah well
you [ __ ] it up for everybody yeah
thanks thanks a lot um listen boys and
girls we gotta get here because i think
they got to replace the ice or something
yeah i don't know there's a heart out
but have you had a good time tonight
um
there is we certainly have had a
fantastic time not to speak for you
maybe oh no please speak for me quickly
yeah yeah i yeah i mean i have a it's
such a great time up here
um yeah it's real quick so i grew up in
a part of michigan where uh we got cbc
broadcast
so i watched those more than i did in
american tv so i i grew up on on kids in
the hall i love you know i'm crushing
everybody's head to my
crush you know yeah i you know people
don't like it because i have a cabbage
for a head like what the hell is up with
that the chicken lady all that 50 helens
agree yeah but i think one thing that
changed my life and kind of
why i became friends with kevin was
because i watched grassy junior high and
and then later to jackie high
you know i wanted to be joy jeremiah i'm
i'm still in love with with caitlin like
even though stacy miss disson so in love
with her and now we're kind of friends
through the con world um but yeah larry
if you cut me open a little there's a
there's there's there's there's tim
hortons and maple syrup that bleeds onto
me
so i really well you know thank you for
the warm welcome like i truly love
canada and this country and um i'll take
any opportunity to come back up here
yeah for sure man this is my third fan
con
um and i would not come back if i don't
have a great time every time yeah for
sure so thank you norm wherever he is
thank you
and
fight some fires thank you to prince
george for always being so welcoming
thank you to you guys for showing up
with us thank you to ming chen
thank you for rolling hard
and uh and that's another episode of
black man beyond um
tune in uh tune in tuesday
uh tuesday even though none of you can
make it to the cantina uh kevin and i
are returning to the cantina after his
months-long sabbatical making clerks
three um so yeah tuesday night we'll be
we'll be rocking it live at 8pm so same
black time same black channel
[Laughter]
smodcast.com or youtube.com kevin smith
good night everybody good night
everybody thank you
[Applause]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask of anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith